la parole est un Monsieur Emmanuel
Mendon pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des Affaires étrangères
cette nuit en Ukraine sabotage a détruit
partiellement une infrastructure civile
majeure le barrage hydroélectrique de
cacovka les conséquences de ce crime de
guerre sont tragiques et à l'heure où
nous sommes réunis nous constatons des
villes et villages ont été engloutis des
dizaines de milliers d'Ukrainiens
luttent pour leur survie la centrale de
saporiccia menaçait de surchauffe et
surveiller de très près par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique une
catastrophe écologique sans précédent à
l'échelle de plusieurs régions ce profil
madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous communiquer les dernières
informations dont vous disposez sur
cette catastrophe avant nous une idée
précise de l'aide d'urgence qui pourrait
être apportées à nos amis Ukrainiens
mais au-delà cet événement nous rappelle
que Vladimir Poutine Krel ko qu'il avait
annoncé en pratiquant la terreur
systématique par la terre brûlée et
aujourd'hui les terres inondées nous
sommes au 16e mois d'une guerre
de haute intensité qui s'enlise
s'élargit révèle une escalade constante
dans les destructions et les menaces
nous allons ainsi au fil des mois de
sidération sidération l'Europe par la
voie du président Charles Michel affirmé
ce matin avec la Russie devrait rendre
des comptes dans ce contexte effrayant
madame la ministre pourriez-vous nous
préciser si la France compte de
nouvelles initiatives diplomatiques à
l'encontre de la Russie pour dénoncer
son action criminelle et la placer face
à ses responsabilités devant l'histoire
je vous remercie